ich habe über Monate hinweg eine winzige
23 Quadratmeter Wohnung im Herzen von
Köln zu meiner absoluten Traumwohnung
umgebaut und heute zeige ich sie euch
viel Spaß
[Musik]
das gesamte Video ist mit dem Google
Pixel 7 Pro entstanden welches voll mit
Foto und Video Features steckt wie zum
Beispiel den Movie Modus welche nicht
gerade benutze damit ich scharf bin und
der Hintergrund unscharf die Wohnung
befindet sich in super zentraler Lage in
Köln im beliebten Viertel Ehrenfeld der
Grüngürtel ein Park der sich komplett um
Köln erstreckt ist zu Fuß erreichbar in
direkt daneben gibt es alles was man
braucht also Busse Bahnen Einkaufsläden
und eine Menge Restaurants und Clubs und
Bars wofür Ehrenfeld so ein bisschen
steht und das Haus wurde 1973 gebaut
fast insgesamt 21 Wohnungen und eine
davon ist eben die hier
das Haus ist ziemlich einfach gebaut und
auf den sehr kleinen 23 Quadratmetern
findet man abseits der großen
Fensterfront die sich auch über die Ecke
erstreckt wenig Luxus kein Balkon oder
sonstiger Schnickschnack einfach nur ein
Raum was aber auch nicht immer so war
als ich die Schlüssel bekommen habe gab
es eine Wand die den Flur inklusive
Kochnische und Badezimmer vom Wohnraum
getrennt hat deshalb vor allem den
Eingangsbereich der Wohnung extrem
dunkel gemacht direkt neben der
Eingangstür befand sich das Bad das
ebenso wie die gesamte Wohnung ziemlich
gepflegt aber einfach sehr alt war eine
Sitzwanne mit Stufe ein altes WC
Waschbecken und Durchlauferhitzer durch
den Flur an der dunklenkoch nicht vorbei
ging es in den Wohnraum in dem sich
einen Einbauschrank befand neben dem
Bett hätte hier nicht mehr besonders
viel Innenraum gepasst und die Kochen
Nische war für meinen Geschmack auch
nicht groß genug im Prinzip aber die
perfekte Basis für mein Projekt ziel
sollte es nämlich sein alten kleinen
bestehenden Wohnraum in einer großen
Stadt neu zu denken und den wenigen
Platz einfach besser zu nutzen und um
bei so wenig Platz alles trotzdem
perfekt filmen zu können nutzen wir das
Ultra sogar vom Google Pixel das uns
ermöglicht alles drauf zu haben und die
Wohnung vielleicht etwas größer wirken
zu lassen als sie eigentlich ist ohne
auch nur einen Funken Ahnung zu haben
begann ich damit die Wohnung auszuräumen
und zu entkernen die Wand der
Einbauschrank und die Einrichtung des
Badezimmers wurden entfernt so dass es
wirklich nur noch ein Raum plus
Badezimmer war ich habe euch dann darum
gebeten eure Traumwohnung zu gestalten
und sie bei mir einzureichen was ihr
fleißig getan habt nach einer Vorauswahl
von fünf verschiedenen Plänen habt ihr
euch dann für den Plan Apartment die von
Markus Kirchner entschieden der zu dem
Zeitpunkt noch Architekt war so konntet
ihr mitgestalten mit entscheiden und
direkten Einfluss aufs Projekt nehmen
was ich super cool finde den Plan von
Markus habe ich dann noch mal leicht
angepasst umgesetzt und so kommt es dass
wir jetzt hier eine fertigen Wohnung
sitzen und ich sie euch zeigen kann von
der Eingangstür gelangt man nun durch
eine stumpf einschlagende Raum hohltür
ins Badezimmer der gesamte Raum wurde
fugenlos gespachtelt wodurch das Bad
deutlich deutlich größer heller und
moderner wird ein neues Waschbecken ein
neuer Handtuchheizkörper und ein
moderner Monolith mit eingebautem
Geruchs abzuholen installiert und die
synchromarmaturen wurden durch moderne
mattschwarze Armaturen ersetzt die
Sitzwanne wurde entfernt und durch einen
extra flachen Ablauf konnte eine
bodentiefe Dusch eingebaut werden was
eines meiner Highlights in der Wohnung
ist auch hier gibt es neue Armaturen mit
Regendusche aber das Bad ist leider noch
nicht ganz fertig seit Wochen vermassel
ich es immer wieder die Abdeckung für
die Lüftung anzubringen glücklicherweise
kann ich das Loch zumindest auf Fotos
mit wenigen Klicks dank des magischen
radiererwerkzeugs das Google Pixel ganz
einfach verschwinden lassen der Fußboden
außerhalb des Badezimmers wurde
nivelliert um Fischgräten Parkett zu
verlegen was den Raum deutlich
wohnlicher und wirklich luxuriös wirken
lässt die Wohnung ist nach Norden
ausgerichtet was den Vorteil hat dass
wir super weiches Licht haben aber den
Nachteil das grundsätzliche relativ
wenig Licht da ist weswegen das super
wichtig war dass ich mich für helle
Materialien entschieden habe also viel
Holz und viele Weißtöne das abgerundet
mit schwarzen Armaturen schwarzen
Griffen und einer Menge Pflanzen in
verschiedenen Größen für die gesamte
Wohnung und dank das makrofokus das
Google Pixel kann ich euch das auch
wirklich aus nächster zeigen die
verschiedenen Pflanzen Oberflächen und
alles ohne Detail super nah an die
Kamera ran holen zwischen im Bad und der
Küche haben wir den Einbauschrank
geplant in dem der Durchlauferhitzer und
ein neuer Schaltschrank Platz finden die
vorher beide im Raum hängen was
überhaupt nicht schön war die Küche hat
einen in der Wand eingelassenen
Hängeschrank damit dieser nicht in den
Raum ragt neben Kühlschrank Schränken
und Arbeitsfläche haben wir ein zwei
Feld großen Induktionsherd eingebaut und
uns für eine Eichen Arbeitsplatte
entschieden um den Holzturm vom Boden
und der neuen schmaleren Fensterbank
wieder aufzugreifen insgesamt ist die
Küche deutlich größer geworden aber es
ist einfach immer noch wenig Platz und
das lässt sich nicht wirklich ändern um
den Flur nicht unnötig breit werden zu
lassen und dort Platz zu verlieren haben
wir uns entschieden zwischen Küche und
Bett ein extra tiefen Raum hohen
Apothekerschrank als Kleiderschrank zu
verbauen auch in voll ausgezogener
Position bleibt genug Platz um den
Spiegel der an der Front des Schrankes
montiert ist zu nutzen
im Boden und Essbereich haben wir uns
für einen Klapptisch entschieden um
nicht dauerhaft ein Tisch rumstehen zu
haben den man vielleicht gar nicht so
oft braucht sollte man dann doch mal
Gäste haben oder arbeiten wollen finden
hier bis zu drei Leute Platz
[Musik]
der gesamte Wohnbereich beziehungsweise
die gesamte Wohnung ist weil wir die
Wand los geworden sind und dank der
Riesen Fensterfront wirklich hell und
man kann fast 180 Grad in die Stadt
schauen und dann das super Resolution
des Google pixels Dinge in der Ferne
super nah dran holen und in bester
Qualität
hinter der Küche und hinter dem
Apothekerschrank ist ein 1,40 x 2 m
großes Bett verbaut unter dem eine Menge
Stauraum für allerlei Kram ist den man
im Alltag nicht braucht der Mechanismus
um den Lattenrost hoch zuklappen und den
Platz darunter aber wirklich nutzbar zu
machen muss noch nachgerüstet werden und
um keinen Fernseher an die Wand hängen
zu müssen was ich einfach nicht
besonders schön finde haben wir einen
Beamer verbaut für den wir extra Strom
an die Decke gelegt haben dank des
nachtsicht-modus können wir so den
Filmabend auch bei schlechten
Lichtverhältnissen perfekt festhalten
und das geht natürlich in allen anderen
Situationen mit schlechtem Licht auch
[Musik]
ziel war es alten kleinen schlecht
genutzten Wohnraum möglichst modern und
smart nutzbar zu machen ohne dabei auf
Rentabilität schauen zu müssen so ein
Projekt ist natürlich nur mit Partnern
möglich weswegen ich unheimlich happy
bin das Google Pixel mich bei diesem
Video unterstützt hat und außerdem finde
ich wirklich erstaunlich wie wenig man
merkt dass dieses Video auf einem Handy
produziert ist und nicht mit einer knapp
10.000 € Kamera es ist de facto fast
kein Unterschied mehr zu sehen und alles
was ihr braucht um selber mit YouTube
starten zu können und irgendwann
vielleicht solche Projekte umzusetzen
ist ein vernünftiges Handy und genau das
findet ihr wie man sieht in Google Pixel
auf jeden Fall natürlich möchte ich euch
den Zuschauern aber auch eine
Möglichkeit geben mal für ein
Wochenendtrip oder wofür auch immer hier
in der Wohnung zu schlafen und genau das
wird bald für einige Monate möglich sein
für alle Gäste haben wir einen Flyer mit
Infos zu Wohnung und der Umgebung
erstellt den wir mit der
live-übersetzungsfunktion des Google
pixels direkt in der Kamera App wie der
Name schon sagt live übersetzen könnt
gerade für die Leute unter euch dieser
verreisen ist das unheimlich interessant
und damit ihr dieses und alle weiteren
Features selber mal testen liegt hier
ein Google Pixel in der Wohnung bereit
dass sie über den Mietzeitraum komplett
frei nutzen können zum Fotos machen zum
orientieren oder wofür auch immer das
war's genau hiermit endet das
Wohnungsprojekt ich hoffe es hat euch
gefallen ich hoffe ihr hattet Spaß
vielen Dank für den Support vergesst
nicht dieses Video zu liken und den
Kanal zu abonnieren wenn es noch nicht
gemacht habt und wir sehen uns in den
nächsten Tagen wieder macht's gut